how do I put this nicely smartphones
have become boring all the black slabs
look the same and have comparable
cameras processors and screens yep
they're a snoozefest well not all of
them actually this new LG g5 is proof
that some phone makers are still after
ideas that will wow us now don't get me
wrong I don't think you should buy this
thing the Samsung Galaxy s7 and the
iPhone 6s are far better when it comes
to camera battery life and design so
know LG's latest may not be our phone of
the present but it points to the future
yep we're going to the future to see
what our phones will look like the g5
has a secret talent its bottom half
slides out so you can attach different
accessories it's a glimpse at modular
design think of it like mr. potato head
of smartphones you add and remove parts
to make the phone look and act as you
want the g5 s modules or friends are
limited at the moment the most exciting
one is this camera grip Google's project
ara team is designing a modular phone
with far more flexibility though you can
swap the screen storage speakers camera
and more speaking of cameras the g5 has
two cameras on its back and here in the
future we all have multiple cameras on
our smart phones so we can take
incredible shots even ones in 3d a
startup called light says with six to
eight lenses a smartphone can take shots
as good as this thing more cameras mean
capturing more of the scene drastically
improving low-light performance and
better depth of field eventually the
cameras will capture 3d 360 degree shots
no need for Samsung or LG external 360
cameras and you'll be able to see those
3d 360 shots by attaching your phone to
a virtual reality headset or as a
hologram that jumps right off your phone
screen oh yes a startup called Leia 3d
is working on special projection
technology that pops images right off
the screen
yeah I'm not entirely down with Harley
graphic selfies but what I am sold on is
wireless charging in the future we don't
have any of these I'm not talking about
those silly wireless charging pads I'm
talking about wireless power that
behaves like Wi-Fi as soon as you walk
into a powered area your phone begins
charging and hopefully your brain
doesn't start to fry
companies like hacia and energies are
working on transmitters and receivers
needed for true wireless power of course
the question for all of this is when end
of 2017 early 2018 second half of 2017
mid to late 2017 so by 2018 I should be
holding a modular smartphone that's
wirelessly charging with eight cameras
while my video chat with a hologram of
my mom yeah I don't think so it's likely
to take longer than that but smartphones
are going to wow us again we just have
to wait all right